Alright guys, so this is a brand new course and every week there will be a new chapter that's gonna be released in the Discord server. And in this very first chapter I'm gonna teach you guys about the Monday range. It is a very good model with high wind rate. It works on gold, NAS100, EuroUSD,
So essentially what we are doing is we are marking out high of the Monday and low of the
Monday.
So let's assume that this candle on the daily time from is the Monday candle and it closes.
So we mark out the Monday high and the Monday range low.
Now on Tuesday we want to see price take out either the swing or the Monday high or the
Monday low.
So let's assume that on Tuesday the low is taken out.
the low of the Monday is taken out.
What we want to do is we want to simply drop down to 15 minute
timeframe. So we will drop down to 15 minute timeframe.
And then we're going to look for a market structure shift.
Right. And we're going to take our entry and we can target the Monday
high or we can take our profit at the 50% of this Monday range. Right.
So we can take our profit somewhere around here or we can simply go for one
Now, key thing to note is that you should get your market structure shift during London session
because let's assume that you get your market structure shift during Asian session.
Now, this will then become the Asian session low.
So there's a chance that price will take out the Asian low first and then give you another
market structure shift and move towards the Monday.
Hi.
So remember this one thing, we are looking for market structure shift during London or
New York session.
If the market structure shift occurs during the Asian session, right, then we have to keep
the Asian range strategy in the first course in our mind.
And we have to think about it logically, right?
Because if we get the market structure shift during the Asian session, we can expect the
price to take out the issue low first and then move towards the Monday high.
So similarly, if the Monday candle high is taken out first,
we're going to drop down to the 15 minute timeframe. Right.
And then we're going to look for a market structure shift.
And then we're going to look to take our entry from the fair value gap or an
auto block.
And we're going to target the Monday low, very simple.
Okay, so to increase the probabilities we can do is look for S&T divergence. It is not necessary, but what's gonna do is gonna
confirm
You know the
Momentum, but it's not necessary and it requires this model requires no device and this is like a one trade per week setup and
It has a very high event rate
So if you are someone who has you know a 95 job or you just busy with your family or what not
You can just take one set of per day and make a living.
So I'm gonna give you guys some examples and then I'll be back next week with a new chapter.
Okay guys, so here is example number one and you can see this is the Monday candle and that close.
So all you have to do is mark out the Monday candle high and the Monday candle low.
So you can see that on Tuesday the low of the Monday candle was taken out.
So if I drop down to 15 minute time from right.
This is the Monday low, and it was taken out first.
And we have our Monday high over here.
So you can simply see that what happened.
We got a market structure shift, right, during the kilos and ours.
And then you can see that we had this breaker block.
afterwards price tapped into this and it just flew away. Now of course this is
hindsight. Primarily you want to be trying to take your entry from the auto
block right but since the range was so big you want to get into the trade as
soon as possible. So for example even if I took my trade here right I put my
stop somewhere around here. This would have easily given me around 3.51. Okay? The general rule
of thumb, a very good rule of thumb is that you always go for one to two wrist or a ward, right?
And all of us go break even after one to one is hit. So that was a very clean example. Let's move
on to another example now. Okay guys, so in this example you can see that I've marked out the
Monday candle high and the Monday candle low.
So you can clearly see how well this paid out.
So I'm gonna drop down to 15 minute time from here.
And if I zoom out a bit, you can see that
the Monday low was here and it was taken out on Tuesday.
Then simply what we would do is we would look
for a market structure shift and that happened
just around here.
Now, if you see this, that we were outside decales on ours.
Now you could have taken your entry from this break of vlog here, right?
But eventually what I would do is I would wait for the next day and the next London session to start.
And then I would look for a liquidity perch.
So continuation perch in the first course, right?
Afterwards we have a break in the structure.
Then we have the auto vlog here.
And you can see the beautiful delivery to the upside, taking out the Monday candle.
Hi.
Let's be one to another example.
All right, guys.
So here is another example.
This is going to be a different example because I'm going to show you a loser.
And I'm going to also show you that as long as you have, you know, your idea, right,
you can still get reenter into the trade.
So over here, you can see we have the Monday high.
and the Monday low. Right? So if I go to the 15 minute timeframe, you can see that the Monday
high was taken out first. So what we were doing is looking for a market structure shift.
So over here, what we had, we had the Asian session high taken out. And somewhere around here,
we had a market structure shift. And now we did push up, we did mitigate this auto block,
auto block and then we did go below it. But price had another push up right and then afterwards
we had a shift in the market structure over here right and over here. So then we had this auto
block here and you can see the beautiful tap and you can see how price delivered by taking
out the Monday low. Alright guys so here is another example. This time looking at gold so
So you can see on Monday, we have a Monday high and the Monday low.
So now you can see that price first took out the Monday low and then went up ahead and took
out the Monday high.
So if I go to the 15 minute time from here, you're going to see that on Tuesday, we had
a purge on the Monday low.
And that's what we want to see afterwards.
What do we have is if you see, look closely, this is a high.
Right?
this was broken and then what we were simply doing is taking our entry from the
brick-a-block or a fair value gap. So you can see that we have this fair value gap
and the entry was perfect right here and you can see that the draw on liquidity
was taken out. So you can see that we had a push up you could have gone break even
at somewhere around here right after these hives were taken out or at one to one and
And this would have a breakdown perfectly.
So let me realize one more example.
All right, guys, so here is the last example.
You can see that we have a Monday candle,
Monday high, and the Monday low.
So you can see the Monday high was taken out first.
So if we go to the 15 minute time from here,
you can see that I have marked out the Monday high over here.
And on Tuesday, the Monday high was taken out.
So now we're looking for a market structure shift,
the market structure shift happened just around here.
And then what we have is a consecutive bullish
channels to the upside.
This could be your entry level.
Right?
So a shot position just right here.
Stop right above here.
And you can see that the take profit was easily hit.
So that is it for this chapter guys.
I really hope that this works out for you.
There are a lot of more models coming out. I can't wait to show you guys, but I'm gonna keep it slow
One model per week because I want you to get familiar with every single model
And I want you to practice every model because at the end of this brand new course
You're gonna tank me, okay? So just keep watching keep back practicing and keep back testing